foreign
hey guys Pete here today I'll be talking
about House of the Dragon episode 8. the
one where we finally reached the point
we were rushing to the end of one of our
main characters stories this involved
another big time Jump that I thought
felt a lot more abrupt than the previous
one but I don't want to dwell on that
much because this should be the last one
and perhaps more importantly the end
delivered in a way that it appears to
have Justified the means I do think it
makes sense to talk about what happened
in the years we missed up front since we
get those details spread out over the
course of the episode it's been quite a
while since Lena's funeral where Eamonn
claimed vegar and Allison demanded an
eye for an eye that Affair chilled
relations for all involved to the point
of them just basically staying away from
each other Damon and raniera settled in
at Dragonstone after their Valyrian
style wedding they had two children
together with a third on the way and
even though when she was young she
lamented the idea of being trapped in a
castle pumping out heirs that appears to
be the lifestyle she chose as an adult
it does seem to suit her though and her
family turned out a lot more well
adjusted than her half-siblings did in
King's Landing we don't get much about
what Damon's been up to Beyond searching
for dragon eggs to connect with his
Valyrian Heritage but based on the
number of kids he's produced it would
appear that he's moved on from his
erectile dysfunction phase in King's
Landing viserys's Health has continued
to deteriorate 20 years ago he was on
the doorstep of death and managed to
hang on but his decaying face tells us
that his time on Earth is coming to an
end he spends most of his time in bed
loaded to the gills on milk of the poppy
and for what it's worth it looks like
his pain is such that he probably needs
it this means ruling is Left To His Hand
in his Queen
Otto and Allison are in charge and
things seem to be about the same Beyond
a cosmetic shift away from the Targaryen
orgy art towards the face of the seven
Motif it appears to be business as usual
Ina Westeros enjoying a peaceful period
in its history as a book reader I do
wonder what happened to Allison and
viserys's third son Darren who has a
fairly major role in what's to come but
I don't see any evidence that he exists
in this episode the other children have
mostly shed the endearing traits they
exhibited as youngsters to become real
pieces of War work that is with the
exception of Helena who's been relegated
to producing heirs for her older brother
aegon I don't think they make it
explicit how many of those there are but
she does refer to their children when
she asks after the serving woman that
aegon raped Helena is fast becoming one
of my favorite characters because as a
dreamer she literally sees future events
but because she's a little weird no one
even notices that the things that she
says are prophetic there's a part of me
that hopes that no one ever figures this
out and considering how big of a
revelation this would have been for
viserys I kind of love that he never did
his boys with Allison turned out to be
awful aegon is on serious and lecherous
and unsurprisingly after Eamonn claimed
the biggest weapon in the realm as a
teenager he became the kind of guy who
is in a constant state of sizing
everyone up it's almost as if the author
is telling us that it's a mistake to
give these people so much power at a
young age what could go wrong it's also
a little baffling that the heir of the
Iron Throne who knows that their claim
will likely be challenged hasn't been
trying to secure her position in the
capital we do know that viserys was
opposed to the idea of Damon and raniera
getting together they also did that
rather quickly after their respective
Partners died which would have been seen
as disrespectful so maybe there was real
tension after they got married that is
how it played out in the book but they
changed a lot about the period of when
that relationship developed for the show
there were a few times when I was
watching this episode where I was like
the show is really leaning towards
renera and her family in an
uncomfortable way I went into this
episode expecting to see raniera calling
for surveyman's head and then feeding
his body to Cyrax before they ever went
to King's Landing where all of his
people would get their tongues cut out
and with the added Twist of lenor's
ending last week her side was starting
to feel like the flawed But ultimately
good Force coming up against the evil
that is the high Towers in a story that
I never read in such a black and white
way you had pure little perfect angels
that through no fault of their own had
to deal with the stigma of being
bastards versus a raper and an unhinged
looking warrior with a giant chip on his
shoulder so I was pleasantly surprised
when fate intervened in the closing
moments to at least keep things
interesting but at the same time it
brings up some other questions that
we'll get into later the thing that
brings them all together is a potential
crisis in Valerian land we get an
exposition dump of a short conversation
at high tide between rainy's and
corliss's brother vehman apparently the
sea snake has been off fighting in the
stepstones again for six years and he
suffered a severe injury that may be the
end of him Damon channels his second son
energy and makes his case that he should
inherit the throne rather than Rainier a
son Luke it's interesting that there's
no mention of Lena's line whatsoever in
any of these conversations Bayla is on
hand to witness the conversation and she
sends word to her father Damon at
Dragonstone their show spends a few
moments to show us that nothing really
important happened in the six years that
we missed out on Jason Joffrey gruesome
raniera is pregnant again and she and
Damon seem to be just living their lives
at Dragonstone being as Targaryen as
possible even though Allison and Otto
are running things in King's Landing and
you would imagine that they would have
gotten word that the king's Health was
in bad shape apparently there hasn't
been a good reason to visit there in all
that time we're also meant to infer that
Beyond sending Baylor to be a ward of
house valarian they never really patched
things up in relation to their plan to
make everyone fear they were capable of
killing lanor and the effect that would
have on his mother and father because
vaman and rhaenys are on their way to
discuss succession in King's Landing
they do decide to follow to try to
protect Luke's claim the tone is set
when no one comes to welcome them this
was a deliberate slight and I loved
announcing their titles to basically no
one but I also like the subtle
differences in how the red keep looks so
lifeless compared to how we saw things
back in episode 1 in the early days of
viserys's Reign when they go inside
renira mentions that she doesn't
recognize the red keep with all the
seven-pointed stars everywhere and when
we get a look at the small Council we
see that Allison is rocking around
rather large one around her neck I
believe what they're going for here is
that she's trying to be repentant for
what she did at the end of the last
episode she knew that what happened
there would get out and people would
think she was mad and I believe this is
all part of trying to rehabilitate Her
Image it also sets her apart from this
family that she's married into but it
also may work to make her more relatable
to the people who are largely religious
on her way to greet rhaenyra Allison
gets news of that delicate situation
that happened in aegon's quarters she
gets this news from Eric Cargill and
there's a funny thing here of him being
a twin you have Eric and Eric that sound
pretty similar but are spelled
differently he kind of brings this up
when she doesn't realize which one she's
talking to and we do see the two twins
sparring together later in the scene in
the yard
her having to go talk to Diana gives
raniera a chance to go see her father
first and when you see the cobwebs on
his giant model of baleria you know that
things are not as they once were they
find him in bed where he's completely
broken and bedridden they mentioned the
issue of succession at drift Mark and
how they need his support and then they
introduce him to their two children
aegon and viserys I always enjoyed the
fact that ranera and Damon named their
first child together aegon sort of as an
Fu to Allison and when the king learns
that they named their second son viserys
he gets a smile on his face and says now
that is a name Fit For A King which was
a great little moment he brightens up at
first and then we see that this pain is
real and it overtakes him to the point
that he asks for his milk of the poppy
as I've already mentioned aegon is a
terrible human he raped one of the
servants and that sets up a complex if
not uncomfortable conversation between
her and Allison she does comfort the
young woman while threatening her at the
same time this response doesn't seem
like it's the first time that she had to
deal with this it doesn't necessarily
seem out of line for what someone in her
position might say to someone in this
position I think they may be saying that
she can see some of herself in this
person while still being in a position
where she basically Lords over her and
because of what happened in the last
episode and the way this character has
been developing I felt like there was a
real chance that it might have been a
farce and that there was poison in that
cup rather than Moon tea so then goes to
her son who tries to say it was harmless
fun and play it off I'm not really a
proponent of people slapping their
children even when they're adults but
you kind of see where this one comes
from and when she says that he's no son
of hers it also kind of feels like her
being awful but I think it's also
supposed to read that she really has no
idea what to do with him anymore he
laments that he tries so hard and it'll
never be good enough and frankly we
haven't seen enough of any of that to
have that carry any weight I think this
uncertainty about her son's Fitness to
rule ties into her feeling uneasy about
making Bame in the air But Otto does
what Otto does and makes a fair case
about putting a child in charge of the
biggest Fleet in Westeros which you know
would make sense if the whole system
wasn't built on doing exactly that Luke
wouldn't be the first case where this
has happened not by a long shot and if
they were truly worried about his age
they could just as easy make Waymond or
rainey's the Regent until he got older
it's all about calling renera's claim
into question and this is the exact type
of maneuvering they claim to be afraid
will happen if she becomes the queen
raniera goes to rhaenys who is
understandably still upset because she
thinks she had her son killed so that
she can marry Damon rhaenyra tries to
argue her case which after all she's not
lying she didn't have lanor killed but
rainy's doesn't think it matters because
the high towers are still going to come
out on top even when presented with a
marriage proposal that would solve all
their problems she decides to stand on
her own and it's worth noting that this
would also solve Damon's problem about
the bloodline being snuffed out too but
even that isn't enough to convince her
to go against Otto and Allison because
she believes they're going to force her
to her knees with things looking Grim
raniera goes to see her father to ask
for his help one more time she asked
about aegon's dream and points out that
he said that a Targaryen had to rule to
keep the realm together but by naming
her Heir he divided it she questions
whether she wants it because it's a
heavy burden to bear and so she asked
him to defend her and her children but
he's so hopped up on milk of the poppy
that he doesn't respond to anything she
says the next day we get a look at his
morning routine whatever is happening
with him they never really make it clear
it looks unbelievably painful he still
has the sore is that we first saw in
episode one and there isn't much more
left of him as the maesters are tending
to him he tells Otto that he wants to
have dinner with his whole family at
court Otto sits the throne as hand and
Bayman makes his plea they pretty much
set up what he says here with the words
that he spoke at Lena's funeral in his
mind he's golden he has the truth he has
the hand the queen and rhaenys behind
him and he essentially does right up
until the saris walks through the door
in a shocking turn of events he hobbles
his way to take his place on the Iron
Throne as the King of the Seven Kingdoms
this was a terrific surprise that you
didn't really see coming and I loved how
they stretched it out so that we could
feel how difficult this was for him to
do the reactions on everyone's faces
while this is happening are Priceless
renyra sees her father come through for
her the greens realized they were on the
verge of setting things in motion for
aegon's Ascension and they have the rug
pulled right out from underneath them
and based on the history between these
two brothers that we've seen play out
through the first seven episodes it
really landed when we saw him drop his
crown and Damon come to help him make it
the rest of the way Becerra says he's
surprised because rhaenys is right there
and surely she can tell the court what
her husband's wishes are she makes a
real-time decision to leave vaman
holding the bag and jumps right back
over to support Luke and raniera this
guy hasn't done much to endear himself
to fans but you have to feel for him at
that moment he's left alone looking
straight up treasonous on what was
supposed to be his big day he would have
had a big come up here and when all was
said and done the crown would have owed
him instead he gets baited into telling
the truth in front of everyone and
before viserys can take his tongue for
it Damon chops his head in two while
managing to leave the tongue there just
in case viserys wants to have his go
there is so much to like about this
scene that I'll definitely come back to
I mean you had the culmination of the
arc between these brothers when they had
their moment on the stairs but what
stood out to me on the first watch was
how even though everyone knew vaman was
telling the truth even the hightowers
who were unmistakably on his side knew
that this was the inevitable outcome for
saying what he said it's like we were
right there with you right up until you
took Damon's bait and said those words
out loud and then well what did you
expect would happen it's all wrapped up
in this moving scene from a character we
spent enough time with to give it some
real emotional weight and it's all about
an unspoken agreement to maintain a lie
it's like the golden mask he wears to
cover his face if we all agree it's not
hiding a hideous wound then it isn't
there it's about the nature of power and
what people believe that is and even
though his is absolute it's also
something that he has to wield because
if not someone else will step in to that
space and there's a short scene with
rainey's contemplating what just
happened you have to imagine she's also
thinking about the children that she
lost six years ago and what she might do
next and then they all gather for dinner
where she's notably absent things start
off somewhat awkward enough time has
passed that these people don't really
know each other anymore and after
viserys is carried in he pleads for them
all to set aside their differences he
pulls a legendary move when he takes off
the mask he wants them to see him not as
the king but who he really is a father a
brother a husband a grand sire and in
that instant it seems like it might work
this is a man who spent his life trying
to rule in a way that would make
everyone happy which is of course an
Impossible Dream he was ultimately
ineffective in that role but here he
doesn't see why this can't happen inside
his own family if not for the crown if
not for the house of the Dragon then
what about just for him after all
despite his shortcomings his has been a
life of Duty renera is moved and she
makes a toast to Allison for staying by
her father's side and apologizes Allison
reciprocates and says that reniro will
make a fine Queen and when this plays
out in the book it sounds more like
they're putting on a show to make the
king feel better but here it looks
somewhat sincere it's as tenuous as it
is genuine though and we see that all of
the kids haven't gotten the memo aegon
continues to be the worst insulting Jace
by propositioning his new future wife
Bela even here though he's able to pull
it back and decides to toast his uncles
instead of getting into an argument When
viserys Calls for music it looks as
though what he was saying might have
gotten through Jace asks Kalina to dance
just because I think he sort of feels
bad for her since no one treats her that
well and the king gets his moment to
enjoy familial Bliss before his pain
kicks back in and he has to be taken out
of the room here is where you see that
his presence and I guess by extension
his power is necessary to make this work
when a roast pig is placed in front of
Eamon bringing up memories of the pink
dread Luke gives a Little Giggle and
that leads to a final toast from one eye
in that he calls them strong boys as an
end around to calling them bastards and
a fight breaks out he's ready to go and
it looks like he could probably take
them both out at the same time but Damon
gets between them to break it up this is
somewhat unintentionally funny since he
looks like a mini version of Damon with
an eye patch put on him so that you
could tell them apart and they both have
that I'm the little brother anyway so
I've got nothing to lose energy you
could tell that the younger man has a
reverence for his uncle though so it
does end there but I feel like you're
supposed to wonder who might come out on
top if these two actually went at it in
just a few minutes after everything
appeared to be coming together raniera
decides is that they should probably
make their way back to Dragonstone part
of why I felt that their toasting was
sincere is because Allison seems to want
her old friend to stay rhaenyra feels
this too and says she'll return on
Dragon back after she gets her children
home there's a brief transition where we
check in with Missouri who we haven't
seen for quite a while we find out that
this servant from the red keep Talia
works for her and is feeding her
information in this episode she was the
one who gave Allison the moon tea for
Diana Talia has shown up in previous
episodes the first one that comes to
mind is her passing through Allison's
room while she was having dinner with
Laris it kind of stood out there to see
someone who worked for her walking
through whenever she was having a
private conversation right now this is
just something to keep in the back of
our minds because there's no indication
of how mazaria will use this information
the episode comes to an end in viserys's
bed his wife comes to him and gives him
his milk of the poppy and he starts to
talk thinking that she's raniera he
answers her question from the last late
night meeting that they had telling her
that he does believe aegon's dream is
true this works to confuse Allison into
thinking that he's talking about their
son aegon instead of the Conqueror and
when he says it's you you are the one
you must do this she thinks he's asking
her to put him on the throne she leaves
him to sleep saying that she understands
and we see a shot of his dagger he says
no more and reaches out his hand there's
a gasp a tear he says my love which I
think it's safe to say he's referring to
Emma and then viserys of House Targaryen
the first of his name King of the Andals
the rhoynar and the first men lord of
the Seven Kingdoms and protector of the
realm closed his eyes and went to sleep
he never woke he was 52 years old and
had reigned over most of Westeros for 26
years and I won't read the next line
from the book because episode 8 ends
there overall a great ending to
viserys's story this episode delivered a
satisfying conclusion that elicited an
emotional response that I found lacking
in most of the other deaths we've seen
with an exception being his wife Emma in
the first episode of the series he
referred to that as a wound that would
never heal and then his whole body
appears to have become that same thing
really though it was a superb
performance by Patty considine bringing
this complicated tragic character to
life and making his death feel like it
mattered there were just so many chances
for things to go differently he could
have named aegon The Heir the day he was
born or he could have prepared rhaenyra
and the realm for her rule he could have
made her the hand instead of bringing
Otto back he could have recognized the
kid's parentage and legitimize them he
could have married her to aegon he could
have married Jace to Helena I mean the
list goes on there were a lot of
alternate routes that maybe don't fall
apart so easily when he mistakes Allison
for his daughter and starts popping off
about a prophecy that twist was
something I struggled with on the first
watch it does feel like it balances
things out in a story that was starting
to skew heavily in favor of rhaenyra but
it also felt like it made things smaller
in a way we had all this buildup that
provided some insight into why Allison
saw things the way she did and this
could undermine a lot of that this isn't
something from the book The Prophecy
itself isn't in there at all and it
feels like this gives her a clear-cut
reason to block runner's claim at the
same time it's a little early to assign
the simplest explanation of what they
might be trying to do it did give them
the chance to Swerve once and have
everybody come together only for that to
fall apart and admittedly part of my
reaction comes from this being different
than what I was expecting and that's
where things get interesting because
here is the thing we know what the
historical count says we know what the
Fire and Blood history says about the
reign of viserys Targaryen and his death
and now we're getting a lot more details
as to what actually happened and so I
think that it makes sense that a show
based on a book that relies on
unreliable accounts might raise the
question of how reliable that
information is can you believe what you
read when it comes to history should you
because it all comes through someone
else after the fact and I think you
should at least keep in mind that it's
probably more complicated than it
appears is that what house of the dragon
is trying to show us for instance in
this case the history is written by men
in a society that is pretty misogynistic
and therefore women are likely to be
painted in an unfavorable light it's
kind of funny because there's a lot of
discourse around which side is right
with fans picking aside like they're
watching sports I've never really had a
clear favorite because it just seems
like trying to decide which group is a
little less wrong when the system is
there to dictate that they have to fight
in the first place it's all entertaining
but none of it seemed really all that
cool to me both sides are capable of
good and bad but the clear thing is that
no one is better off because of their
inability to coexist I like the idea
that it just might be more complicated
than what people are basing their
beliefs on I'm not sure if they'll be
able to make that work but it should be
fun to watch if that's what they're
going for I've enjoyed this show a lot
while having some issues and over the
past two episodes it has started to seem
like most of those nitpicks might
disappear now that we have real payoffs
to things that they've been setting up
we shouldn't be jumping forward in time
anymore and we have the same actors
playing the characters from here on out
but saris's Big scenes in this one pair
nicely with Allison and raniera and
eamon's big ones from last week I have a
good idea of some of what will be
happening in the last two episodes and
think things will only pick up from
there I just think someone ought to
listen to Helena because she actually
knows what's going on and I think that's
a great place to leave things let me
know in the comments what you thought
about this episode and how things played
out at the end there please like this
video If you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon